♪ Party all night ♪
♪ 'Cause it's an
all night party ♪
- What could possibly
be the problem
with letting two more people in?
- Oh, oh!
- All right!
- Oh, here we go!
- Here we got a friend.
- Yep!
- All right!
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat club music)
- [Male Announcer]
All right fellas,
coming to the stage next,
the beautiful, Galaxy.
(man clapping)
- Hey, baby.
Oh.
♪ Read the signs on my body ♪
It's gonna be for you.
(man chuckling)
You can keep it.
There's more where
that came from too.
Trust me.
(man whistling)
- That's my girl.
- Oh, damn.
- I'm straight up talking
about some Darrell Dawkins
right here,
because this some
chocolate thunder.
What girl?
Make it rain!
(man laughing)
Yeah!
Oh, yeah girl.
- I was trying to
make her laugh!
- The fuck?
All right, girl.
Mm, shapow!
I'm gonna get it right
in the booty right there.
And booty swell!
That's what you call
a booty investment.
(man laughing)
Sha-plow!
- But we really don't need
to give 'em that much.
I don't think they're
expecting all that.
- Woo!
- It's kinda like feeding
a squirrel, you know?
I mean they, they will
come back to you, so.
- Oh, oh.
Oh my gosh.
Some of this is getting lost.
Let's get it right
where it need to be,
right in there, baby.
Oh, yeah.
- Keep it classy!
(man laughing)
Keep it classy.
- Oh (beep)!
Somebody better get an umbrella
'cause I can't stop
making the rain.
It's like Noah's flood up here.
Ooh, two by two baby!
Two by two!
(man laughing)
Maybe you don't know
that I'm the general,
'cause it's Stormin' Norman.
That's what they be calling me.
(Velcro peeling)
Damn.
Anyway, like I said,
when you finish training
you get Scotty
Mutsio up in here.
That (beep) can train a boxer.
(car door beeping)
(change clanging)
(man laughing)
Ooh, Lord have mercy!
You don't know
nothing about this.
Make it rain!
(change clanging)
- Ah!
(woman screaming)
Are you an idiot?
Leon, get this guy outta here!
- All right, nobody move!
There he is!
- There who is?
- You, on your feet!
On your feet!
- What'd I do?
- You're under arrest
for photocopying money.
- Oh, god dammit!
You know long it took
me to cut all that out?
I got carpel tunnel
syndrome up in this bitch!
Calluses on the
inside of my thumbs.
- That's definitely real though.
(upbeat club music)
♪ Well tonight we gonna party
'til the party don't stop ♪
♪ And the party don't stop
because it keeps on going ♪
♪ Non-stop gonna
party all night ♪
♪ Gonna keep this party going ♪
♪ Coz the party won't stop ♪
♪ It's been two straight days
and the party's still going ♪
♪ 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 days ♪
♪ 'Til it's Friday again
and the party keeps going ♪
♪ Party all night coz
it's an all-night party ♪
♪ Friday night 9 PM ♪
♪ Hop in the car ♪
♪ Call my friends ♪
♪ Drinks in the back ♪
♪ Girls out front ♪
♪ Going to a party ♪
♪ Sending texts ♪
♪ Cell phone rings ♪
♪ iPad ♪
♪ Facebook ♪
♪ Party time ♪
♪ Skin-tight jeans ♪
♪ Friday night ♪
♪ Dance dance dance ♪
♪ Coz tonight we going out
and we ain't coming back ♪
♪ Coz the party won't stop
it will go all night ♪
♪ Friday night every night ♪
♪ The party's going down ♪
♪ Down down down down
down down down down down ♪
♪ New York City, LA, Chicago ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego ♪
♪ Phoenix, Boston,
Fort Worth, Austin ♪
♪ Memphis, Denver,
Portland, Vegas ♪
♪ Tucson, Fresno, Akron, Tampa ♪
♪ Pittsburgh, Newark,
Plano, Lincoln ♪
♪ Lubbock, Durham,
Salem, Dayton ♪
♪ City, city, city, city ♪
♪ Coz tonight we going out
and we ain't coming back ♪
♪ Coz the party won't stop ♪
♪ It will go all night ♪
♪ Friday night every night ♪
♪ The party's going down ♪
♪ Down down down down
down down down down down ♪
♪ New York City, LA, Chicago ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego ♪
♪ Phoenix, Boston,
Fort Worth, Austin ♪
♪ Memphis, Denver,
Portland, Vegas ♪
♪ Tucson, Fresno, Akron, Tampa ♪
♪ Pittsburgh, Newark,
Plano, Lincoln ♪
♪ Lubbock, Durham,
Salem, Dayton ♪
♪ City, city, city,
city, cities ♪
♪ Now we're gonna
keep it going ♪
♪ To the break of
break of dawn ♪
♪ Then we'll just keep
partying all day long ♪
♪ Hot girls, music, dancing
and bikinis and headphones ♪
♪ Party, party, party, party,
party, party, party, party ♪
(gun firing)
(upbeat club music)
♪ So tonight we gonna party
'til the party don't stop ♪
(upbeat club music)
- Sargent Crandle.
United States Army recruiter.
How y'all doing?
This is my associate,
Sargent Graham Packs.
- Yeah!
- Huh, huh, huh, huh!
(man laughing)
- Nice beat, gentlemen.
- We wanna talk to
you about your future
and where you fit in the
United States Army, y'all!
- Yeah.
In case you haven't heard,
we're asking and your telling.
- That's right!
No restrictions, man.
You're gonna be surrounded
by dudes all day.
Y'all get to exercise together.
You can shower together.
- Talking about soap,
water, the works.
- Now I know what
you're thinking.
The army's dangerous,
but the fact of the matter
is everything's dangerous.
- All depends on
what your definition
of the word danger is.
- Oh, yeah!
- What?
All right.
- Oh, here we go.
- Here we got a friend!
- Yeah.
(man chuckling)
- Yeah, all right.
- Hey, Navy already got him!
(men laughing)
But you better off in the Army.
'Cause we gonna get you the
best shape in your whole life!
- Woo!
Talking about a six pack.
- Flip!
- Gonna give you
an eight pack.
- Slip!
- Hey, we'll even
give you a jet pack.
(man laughing)
- That's a joke, man.
He a joke. He a funny guy.
We ain't got jet packs.
- Oh!
- Oh, that's my cut!
Ooh, what, what!
Cut!
- Cut!
Go ahead.
Hey, hey!
You got to isolate,
then isolate,
then i-so-late.
- Oh yeah!
Let me tell you
something right now, man.
Combat is just a bunch
of men in a tight space.
with flashing lights
and loud noises!
- Just like this.
- Just like this!
- Yeah, you'll fit
right in at home.
- It's gonna be great, man.
Y'all gonna love it.
Oh, here it is.
- There it go.
- Can't stop it.
Can't stop it.
What?
- Go, Crandle.
Sergeant Crandle,
Crandle, Crandle.
And hold it.
- What?
- And hold it right there.
- Woo!
Go Crandle.
All right.
I'm a robot, robot.
- Nope.
(knocking on door)
- Excuse me, young man.
Have you ever thought about
joining the United States Army?
Oh, oh, excuse me.
I will talk to you two later.
Pardon me.
(upbeat club music)
(man sighing)
- Can you totally chilllax?
- No, I'm so annoyed right now.
Can you like, not talk
to me for like a second?
Like, that'd be great.
That'd be fine.
That'd be fine by me.
What?
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
This is bull (beep)!
What could possibly
be the problem
with letting two more people in?
- Check your girl, bro.
- Sorry.
- Excuse me,
what did you say?
Check your girl?
Uh uh, it doesn't
work like that.
No one checks me
because I'm not luggage.
Okay?
So you can go (beep) yourself.
- Meegan, seriously.
Two more people are gonna come
out in a couple of seconds
and then we can go in!
- No!
Let me ask you a question.
What was it like being
in "The Green Mile?"
- He wasn't in "The Green Mile!"
He clearly wasn't in that movie!
- What does Tom Hanks'
penis feel like?
- Meegan!
- Moreover, how does it
feel when swarms of bees
are coming out of your face?
- Seriously, I'm sorry.
It's like her favorite movie.
- Don't apologize for me.
Yeah, this is nice.
This is nice.
You look like Common
meets the Incredible Hulk.
- Meegan.
- When you brought
the frankincense to baby Jesus,
did they like make you
stand outside the barn
because you were too big,
or did they invite you in
with all the other animals?
Don't flare your
nostrils at me, okay?
Do you have any idea
how impolite that is?
- He hasn't moved
his nostrils once
since we got here!
- I saw them move!
- They did not move, Meegan!
- They flared!
- Meegan, they
(beep) did not move!
- His nostrils flared
more than a survivor
from a boat accident.
- What?
- He's not even looking
at me in the eyes.
Okay, you know what?
If you're just going to
continue to be a little prick,
you're gonna get
your ass kicked.
- Don't touch him,
Meegan.
- Crazy bitch.
(woman gasping)
(woman squeaking)
(man sighing)
(man grunting)
(punch smacking)
- Totally love my
nails right now.
(dramatic instrumental music)
I'm so over
everything right now.
Over the floor.
I'm over the sky.
I'm over you.
Over that pussy back there.
You're a pussy!
- Meegan, seriously.
- Whatever!
(kisses smacking)
- Um, excuse me?
- Oh god.
- Hey!
What did you say?
What the (beep)
did you just say?
You guys come back here with
your little itty bitty dicks.
- You best control your lady.
- Yep.
- Excuse me?
Control your lady?
No, he doesn't control me.
'Cause let me tell
you something,
I'm not a remote.
- Meegan, baby,
can we just let this go?
- No, I'm talking to the
pussies of anarchy right now.
- Oh, great.
- Yeah, you.
Why don't you all
gather yourselves,
and why don't you just go
and figure out a way to
(beep) on each other's
leathery peni?
- Hey (beep) you, bitch!
(man groaning)
(woman gasping)
(woman squeaking)
(man sighing)
- It's not even the
plural of penis.
(punches smacking)
- [Biker] Yeah!
- I'm the queen of the world!
Yes!
I feel invincible!
Like I have super
powers or something!
(woman laughing)
You hear that, all you
(beep) of the world?
I can do anything I want
and no one can stop me!
- That's because you don't
have to fight your own fights,
you crazy bitch!
(woman gasping)
Oh boy.
Oh no.
(woman squeaking)
(man sighing)
(man grunting)
(punch smacking)
- Nothing can stop me!
(intense club music)
- [Male DJ] It's Friday night,
make some noise!
(crowd cheering)
Put your motherfucking
hands in the air!
If you cool like a
pimp, put your hands up.
'Cause you an actual pimp,
put your hands up.
If you own a bunch of
women, put your hands up.
(intense club music continues)
If you gonna hit it all
night, put your hands up.
If you maintain an
erection for 12 hours,
put your hands up.
- Woo!
- [Male DJ] Without
the benefit of Viagra,
put your hands up.
(intense club music continues)
If you a real live
player, put your hands up.
If you abuse women's
trust, put your hands.
If you treat her like
objects, put your hands.
(intense club music continues)
If you a real live
gangster, put your hands up.
If you will real live
If you kill other people,
put your hands up.
(intense club music continues)
If you the biggest boss
here, put your hands up.
If you run an actual drug
ring, put your hands up.
If you just realized
that you're full of shit,
put your hands up.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat funky music)
♪ All I want is ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪